Experiencing the Northern Lights is quite the spectacle.
The beautiful light display...
...can only be seen in the late fall and winter months though...
...and only from the northernmost areas of the world...
...or you can head over to Yellowknife.
It's the capital city of the Northwest Territories...
...and is located about 250 miles south of the Arctic Circle.
It's famous for its gold and diamond mines...
...and this city is also referred to as the Northern Lights capital of the world.
Once you leave the city area, you can see the Northern Lights with such clarity...
...that it's gonna take your breath away.
Reykjavik is a beautiful area...
...located on the very edge of the Arctic Circle in Iceland.
It offers one of the most accessible ways to see the Northern Lights.
The only catch is that transportation to and from Iceland can be a bit difficult...
...especially during the winter season when the Northern Lights are most prominent.
And our last city to check out the Northern Lights in is Kiruna, Sweden.
It's the northernmost city in Sweden and is famous for being the perfect place...
...to catch the Aurora Borealis and the midnight sun.
Kiruna is actually located 145 miles north of the Arctic Circle.
If you find yourself looking for a place to stay,...
...be sure to check out the Ice Hotel just outside of Kiruna.